eric what's your favorite place on earth
but who
like for just like just like i mean like
food and everything else like just
generally
not chess well i mean and in terms of
favorite country it has to be iceland
because uh well there you go the the
landscape is amazing
it's it's probably the most photogenic
country
but then in terms of food oh
honestly i really like the food in new
york city oh my god which i know might
might like insult some people but just
all the food is amazing there
i feel so accomplished no no one went
after me you won but you also messed
things up for hikaru because he could
have
he should have been second or third and
you i mean
that's right okay what we're doing now
is we're playing one five free-for-all
so you guys see the end of five what's
one
yeah all right much better much better
okay
all right here we go why does chat keep
saying minus 29
because they're cause that's what that's
how many points i lost oh this is still
free
for all right yes free for all yep okay
why am i so high rated compared to
everyone else
uh it's bullet it's bullet free from
it's the difference
oh oh it's just straight one oh oh no oh
why
what no no it's not it's one o or no it
is one it's
increment okay no it's one five it's one
five okay
yeah i was about to freak out okay no
hikaru is just scaring us to pre-move
everything
okay don't take my bishop please
don't go near my paw [ __ ] it block it
levy you screwed me last game so no
he's playing the last game he screwed me
like five times last night he screwed me
do you guys always do the same thing i
don't
you totally did like you totally did
don't pretend that you didn't wait
what are you but like i'm i think you're
personalized while you play it you
played knight
you tried to bring your queen or rook to
attack my king like with your two
knights
like i'm not having any of it man okay
now what is this yeah we should have
another gun
okay yeah don't don't don't give him a
second queen
now i'm gonna go eric's style as many
queens as possible
but you ooh okay let's bring this guy
isn't this what you tried last game yes
but the different
oh some more like me
oh that's a nice rook lift
okay thank you sensei
what what
okay here we go where is that rook going
it's controlling territory
that's a nice pawn push thank you it's
my g5 move
oh nope i had an idea but
okay nice castles
uh can i just say guys i'm just gonna
i'm just gonna say i think this is the
most enjoyable four player session so
far
it's been it's been the most competitive
i don't know what that means we're good
or we're just all really
the same back i'm just having a good
time it's just like you know four homies
just after like a nice workout you know
strength training
bench press you know spotting for like
antonio i feel like antonio benches like
200 kilos
i i barely even move man
[Laughter]
okay well that's that's fair okay
uh okay i need to block out hikaru's
knights listen
no one's screwing with anybody i just
can't let your knights get closer right
i'm like chael sonnen
can't let you get close weird flags okay
okay
those are good nights good night uh do i
wanna open this
sure sure
this is a hard game
oh but it's the wrong queen love you
again
what what am i doing wrong you you think
i do good things
and i have no idea what i'm doing okay
okay
you shouldn't say anything because then
it gives me ideas you know what i mean
like
okay all right lovey cause then when
you're like
you're doing something i'm like oh i'm
doing something nice i'm gonna
okay
oh you got one
oh you were saying my knight could go
stop it i guess that's well i'll say you
could stop me and then then antonio
could trade the one queen for the
queen yeah i thought that's what you
were gonna do but you're you're
you're fortunately trying to redeem
yourself after last game
correct and uh thank you for mowing me
four thousand i i really appreciate that
right right it says yeah
wait okay i don't know if that's good
but whatever
okay antonio you're like you're not
developing your pieces
he's also giving me a free pawn i'm
developing my queens
what's the um what what
oh that's uh wow it's pretty pretty cool
it's placebo okay
[Music]
yeah i guess yeah i guess it is a free
pawn
that's cool it doesn't change the fact
you still have two queens
yeah and i will get a third one oh
okay is that a threat eric has figured
out some sort of really
eric plays very actively but he like
creates like a weird pawn barrier
right yeah i noticed that yeah it's it's
impressive
i i have no idea what i'm doing i'm just
trying no no
stop it you lie you all
okay whatever i'll happily take my last
place this game
why why do you think you're getting last
place levy no i just played a terrible
move
okay why do you think you're getting
last place says icarus he obliterates my
king's defenses
like how does it frozen can we just get
rosen please like what is this
wait no yes yes
yeah how is he so solid here this is
insane yeah it's like crazy
i thought antonio just plays bishop
takes bishop and i lose so
really i assume but
i'm always foreshadowing my own demise
so
this is hilarious stoned uh
i would i cannot speak on behalf of all
participants but
i know that for myself i am not stoned
okay let's bring that guy in
okay that's uh unpleasant
guys we need to go after eric i mean
this is just ridiculous okay that's
the wrong direction but thank you levi
me and you are the only players without
two queens you pushed me in that
direction
you could have went toward your central
queen nah
okay that's fair you provide good
reasoning
i feel threatened
okay let's just do
this like that
hmm
you can move my king in the wrong
direction
okay oh that's nice
that's nice just repeating
nicely no i just realized i have to run
my king toward yellow because
uh otherwise cara will get me
what now time how is eric so good
i'm about to flag though also trying to
attack me
great he's like a spartan army
i try
okay uh that's a nice square
there we go oh that's actually pretty
bad
that's actually pretty bad
wait for who i don't know it depends on
depends on who plays what right exactly
yeah
oh that's a free rook i i would not have
seen that if you didn't say
it was really bad oh come on
how long does that work i know just now
i i play
i played it there oh that was pretty bad
that was terrible
okay so one rook down a few few to go
um
[Music]
kind of hungry anybody want food
i'm okay but i mean if you're making it
all i'll eat
if you're ordering food i love food from
new york city
yeah doordash uh or uber eats arriving
in what like uh
in 16 hours uh
okay let's uh go for some phone grabs
uber eats helicopter
style they probably will do that at some
point i
think definitely will do that yeah
[Music]
uh
okay
all right what what was that
is one of the draw no are draws possible
in this game
i don't think so no no i guess if like
the score is tied
antonio that's a that's a brutal move
man
i don't want to trade queens i just
wanted a pawn
[Laughter]
because i was on zero points i didn't
want to be on zero points
okay you could have just taken with the
pawn but all right
uh that that is true yeah that is true
i don't know why i did that oh the queen
trade would have killed me but you would
have had chances but
i'm gonna [ __ ] eric a little bit
uh because you stole my rook but you
took my knights
and bishops no you brought the bishop
back i didn't take
anything this is like the weakest
political negotiation i've ever heard
but what oh yes
oh yeah oh my god everyone's attacking
me oh my god
yeah carl i'm not attacking you for the
record i'm there we go
there we go okay let's uh
let's take that one i guess or even
better let's do
no take my legs take my rook yes okay no
don't take the rook why don't you do
that
otherwise oh no i don't know and
um now levy somehow is back in the game
not i just levy is definitely the most
dangerous here
look at these pieces oh how what
okay i guess i'll pick up nine can you
stop
destroying me whatever can't move
whoever can't
move let's just i'm gonna bishop
oh another one wait
wait what wait move your queen hakkar
and then i'll take his queen because
he's a he's more of a threat than me
not really no mate
oh levy i was trying to get a checkmate
i lost my queen to you
so
and get the checkmate yeah but this way
this way i get second probably so
i feel so broke uh great pieces worth
zero points
damn it i didn't know why did you do
that lovey i
that was terrible i just forgot his
queen
[Laughter]
thank you buddy i appreciate it thank
you okay
yeah that's funny huh but levi you're
also getting checkmated so it's not so
trivial
please please because hikaru you you go
first so as long as you just don't
attack me
uh antonio can't beat me he's got two
queens to attack you with man
he wants him he's not good with two he
need like four
or so yeah
[Music]
was there any reason to take my king it
was already dead
i was checking if it will give any
points oh
oh okay okay i thought you were just
trying to torture me even after i died
i just wanted to check that
um this is really annoying antonio
somehow controls all of my promotion
squares like
yeah i was going for that antonio you
just now need to
throw all your pieces away to me what
huh oh i actually missed that
[Laughter]
wait but his king oh you're oh no
what yeah i actually missed that i no i
i just didn't understand like i didn't
see his rook gardening
uh no i didn't see your queen guarding
my rogue
no my queen my queen guard the pawn i
don't think you saw that
yeah it's pretty crazy
okay but it's not cool it's cool
yeah it's cool that's the
yeah it's still not clear at all
if antonio loses a few more pieces maybe
i can get first how does zachary have so
much time
i think you have i can't oh he just
played
i just moved really quickly yeah
so that's the that's the secret
lovey you've been too busy like just
chatting and ordering food
no i always i always play slow i'm also
constantly looking at like the
production and
can you guys stop taking my pieces
[Laughter]
true oh what's that wait i was trying to
maybe think if you could
oh i can't checkmate
i wanted to go queen to a11
right no sorry queen to h11 sorry
is my rook trapped lovey that's the only
move i have
i am not winning by position what what
kind of assertion is that no
icarus completely winning not really
what well he now i am probably
i tried to warn you guys about hikaru
but no one listened everyone attacked me
ouch oh no
sorry lovey no i know but i mean but
eric
if we didn't attack you you you would
have won quite convincingly
i thought my startup was so solid but
then it was if if
like you didn't get like all of us kind
of attacking you you would have won that
game for sure
oh right there's a wait i love how your
queens are one point queens
right they're both one yeah
all right i'm not winning but at least i
got second
that was fun but eric is the best by far
it's not even close
yeah it just happened i don't know how
my rating
i played this is because you play well
and you win most of the time
right but there is that so guys uh it's
it's slow teams
okay yes actually give me a second i'm
just gonna use the restroom sure yeah no
problem
i'm gonna grab some more water
i had this plan to like do all this
preparation
and like get lessons from levy and he
showed me a few things
but then i was going to stay up all
night like preparing last night
and then i fell asleep no